Give therefore thy servant an
understanding heart that I may judge thy
people to discern between the bad and
good. For who can judge this thy so
great a people first Kings chapter 3
verse 9. Welcome to Q&A with Elder Randy
Keat on the word
inspired. I am your host Denanisha
McCerten and today we are discussing
discerning truth from error. Let's have
a word of prayer. Father, thank you for
the blessed privilege of being on this
platform on your holy Sabbath day. We
ask father that your holy spirit would
be among us. Touch our minds, our hearts
to be receptive to your truth. Put your
words in elder's mouth. put your ideas
in his mind, your humility in his heart,
and give us eyes off so that we may see
what is true and what is not. This is my
prayer in Jesus's name. Amen. Amen.
Amen.
Amen. All right. So, our special guest
today, well, you have seen him on the
program many, many times. None other
than Elder Randy SK. And yes, I call him
Papa Ski. Elder Ski is a very consistent
faithful man of God who has devoted his
life to the dissemination of the gospel
of the kingdom, the
unadulterated word of God. And he has
prayed that the Lord would literally put
his words in his mouth. And that is his
desire that whatever he speaks, whether
he eats or drinks, that everything he
does is to God's glory. And we know that
the Lord has been blessing his efforts.
And I believe God will not uh do
anything different from that on this
afternoon. So please help me welcome
Elder Randy
SK. Oh, sorry. You have to unmute. Elder
Ski,
am I all right now? All right. Yes. I
said thank you very much again for this
blessing, this privilege of being with
you on this Q&A and I'm privileged to be
with the online audience wherever you
are. May the Lord bless you. Thank you
very much for this honor and I'll try to
speak the simple word of God to the best
of my ability.
Amen. Amen. Thank you, Papa Sket. So our
first question, what is meant by
dessert?
Desern is a level of comprehension that
exceeds the five
senses. We have the five senses.
Oh, you're muted again. See,
can you hear me now? Yes. All right. I
was saying we have the five senses
seeing, hearing, smelling, tasting,
touching to allow us to navigate the
world in which we live to understand and
to receive sensations and to gather
knowledge.
The question of discernment is one that
is connected to faith and faith is
um indivisible from the word of God.
Discernment allows us to see what we
cannot grasp through the information
that comes through the senses. Now, we
need the senses, but in order to discern
right from wrong, truth from error, the
presence of God as opposed to the
presence of the enemy, we need that
power of discernment. And it is a gift
of the
spirit. So discernment is the ability to
see right through something for what it
really is.
And the church needs that. Why? Because
there are many false prophets and false
spirits that terrorize and harass the
church. For instance, go to 1 John 4:1.
Beloved, believe not every spirit, but
try the spirit whether they are of God.
That try is related to the concept of
discernment. You have to be able to tell
is this the spirit of God in Hebrews
5:14. But strong meat belongth to them
that are full age, even those who by
reason of use have the senses exercised
to discern both good and evil.
Discernment, I say, is the ability to
see through something for what it really
is. And with respect to the church and
spiritual growth, that is a gift of the
spirit. It's listed in 1 Corinthians 12
verse 10, discerning of spirits.
Amen. Amen. Thank you for giving us that
definition of discernment, Elder Ski.
Now, we will answer the existential
question that Pilate asked to Jesus.
What is truth?
When Pilate asked that of Jesus, he was
looking at truth, which is Jesus Christ.
All the entire life of Christ was a life
of truth. Why? Because it was lived in
conformity with the will of God. Truth
actually is the way God sees things.
That is truth. Truth is God's
perspective. Truth is how God sees
things. For instance, if you look at the
the message to the church in Leodysia in
Revelation 3 14- 21, the church said,
"We are rich, increase with goods, and
have need of nothing." That's what they
saw. God said, "You are miserable, poor,
blind, wretched, miserable, poor, blind,
and naked." The truth was what God saw.
Truth is God's perspective of any
situation. There's something called the
uh theory of truth which says that truth
is anything that uh that uh is
consistent with
reality. Truth is whatever is consistent
with God's reality. So if God says
something, in other words, the seventh
day of the Sabbath, that's how God sees
it. That is truth. Any other day you
introduce, however much you sing and
pray on that day, it is not a holy day
because it is contrary to God's reality.
Truth from the biblical standpoint is
that which conso conforms to reality as
God sees
reality. And God's view reality is found
in the Bible. If you want to know what's
on God's mind, read the Bible,
especially the words of Christ. Truth. I
must say it again. Truth again is the
reality as God. God's reality is
truth. There are many Christians who say
you cannot conquer sin. The Bible says
the things which are impossible with men
are possible with God. With God's help,
sin can be conquered. That is God's
reality. Human reality is I cannot
conquer sin. To live a truthful life,
our life must be consistent with God's
view of reality. And I've said it a
thousand times. I'll say it again. It
must be God's view of reality.
Amen. And amen. Thank you for letting us
know that God has a perspective and his
perspective is truth. Well, let me say
something else, my lovely doctor. Yes.
Jesus says, "I am truth." That's what
Jesus said. I am truth. What does he
mean? Did he mean his fingers, his toes,
the garments he wore? No. my life and my
teachings because the life of Christ was
absolutely consistent with what he
taught. Evangelism page 636 paragraph 1.
Christ carried out in his life his own
divine teachings. What he taught he
lived. He taught the talk. He walked the
walk. This is truth with legs on it.
Truth is also God's law that all their
commandments are truth. Malachi 2:6, the
word of the law of truth was in his
mouth. Truth is what the law expresses
and we know the law is exceeding broad.
We cannot plum the depth of God's law
because the law is truth, the law is
righteousness, the law is life. And all
these are divine qualities. They cannot
be plumbed but we must study them. So
truth as I said earlier is that which is
God's reality. That's truth. His view of
reality. Truth is also Jesus Christ
himself. Truth is also the law. 1 John
5:6 says, "The Holy Ghost is truth." So
all of that is truth. Deuteronomy 32:4,
"The Father is truth." Truth is the
reality as the Godhead sees it. And
God's reality is expressed to us from
Genesis to Revelation.
Amen. Anything that differs from Genesis
to Revelation is error and it proceeds
from the devil.
Amen. You know, Papa Ski, so you're
you're letting us know that truth is
absolute. You know, yes, truth is Yes.
Absolutely absolute. Yes.
There's no relativism when it comes to
God's truth. It is absolute. The seventh
day of the Sabbath, case closed.
Amen. Amen. All right. So, I'm going to
add and have Sister Wasan Palmer join
us. She'll be asking the next three
questions. To those of you that have
joined on Zoom, thank you for your
presence. Once again, if you have any
questions on the topic of discerning
truth from error, put it in the chat or
use the raise your hand feature so that
we can acknowledge you at the end. Thank
you.
Amen. Thank you, Sister Tanisha. And
Elder Ski, question number three.
Does discerning require a power beyond
the mind? If so, absolutely that power.
the mind? Let us go to 1 Corinthians
chapter 12. We'll read from verse 8. 1
Corinthians 12, reading from verse 8.
For to one is given by the spirit the
word of wisdom, to another the word of
knowledge by the same spirit, to another
faith by the same spirit, to another the
gift of healing by the same spirit, to
another working of miracles, to another
prophecy, to another the discerning of
spirit. Discernment, spiritual
discernment is a gift of the spirit.
It opens our eyes to see what we
otherwise would not see with simply our
secular vision. It allows us to see
things truly from God's perspective. In
Hebrews chapter 5:14, strong meat
belongth to those who are of full age.
Even those who by reason of use have
their senses exercised to discern.
What's the strong me? The deep study of
the word of God. They are able to
discern good and evil. And so the the
the the the working power in discernment
is the spirit of God through the word or
I should say the spiritfilled word. The
working power in discernment is the
spiritfilled word. It allows us to see
beyond what the physical senses present
to us. So yes, there's a power required
that's beyond our physical senses. That
power is the word of God which is filled
with the spirit of God. Without that
there are a lot of things we simply
would not see. Now I must also say
there's a kind of discernment that is
exercised even by an atheist. It comes
almost naturally. Let me explain what I
mean. Here's a father. Here's a mother
and a son or a girl. The daughter brings
a young man to the house. Say mommy
daddy. This is my friend. His name is
Patrick. You know he goes to college and
we met. And the father spends some time
not much because the father has lived.
And the father discerns. There's
something not right about that young
man. The father discerns it out of son
brings a young lady home. And the mother
discerns. She can't prove it
scientifically and she does not need to.
Her motherly instincts tell her
something is not right about this uh
young young lady that her son has
brought home. And so we have discernment
working that way. But the discernment
that affects us spiritually that helps
us see error from truth that is made
effective by the presence of the spirit
in the word of
God. Amen. Sister, you may ask the next
question.
Okay. How can a limited human mind
discern unlimited divine truth? Okay. A
limited human mind. That's an admission
we must always make whenever we study
the Bible. Whatever we do, we must
always work with the consciousness. Our
minds are limited. Even in the new
world, when we're without sin, we shall
live forever. We see God face to face,
our minds are still limited. Second
Peter chapter 3:18. But grow in grace
and in the knowledge of our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ. That growth does
not end when Jesus comes. We shall grow
and grow and grow no matter how much we
grow. We never reach the level of God
because God is infinite. But we must
grow and grow. And so a finite
mind, how can a finite finite mind grasp
the infinite? A finite mind can only do
this with the assistance of the
infinite. And that is God the Father,
God the Son, God the Holy Ghost. As we
study the word of God and we are willing
to obey John 7:17, if any man will do
his will, he shall know the doctrine.
The willingness to obey is essential to
understanding the Bible. He or she who
studies the word with the willingness to
all will be to obey will be taught and
instructed by the spirit of God. That
person may not have discernment as a
spiritual gift, but the person will
develop the ability to discern. Some
people have something as a gift and
they're very good at it. Others can
develop that over time. We need the
power of the spiritfilled word of God to
open our eyes. David prayed in Psalm
119:18, "Open thou mine eyes that I may
behold wondrous things out of thy law."
If God does not open our eyes, they
think you will never ever see. And so we
need the active work of the spirit of
God through the living word that we may
make sense of divine things. We must
always keep in mind Job 11:7. Can thou
by searching find out God? Can thou find
out the almighty unto perfection? No one
can fully understand God. Only the son
of the Holy Ghost can because they eco
with him. But it is the work of the
spirit through the word that enables us
to grow and grow and understand more and
more. And the more we understand, the
more we become like him as we study and
obey.
Amen. What are blocks of discerning? How
do we remove them? There is one block to
discerning and only one. You can guess
what that is. That is sin. Sin
interferes with our understanding of
God. Sin interferes in our sense of our
duty to fellow man. Sin interferes with
our growth. Sin prepares us for
destruction. Sin in sin creates static
that makes it impossible for us to
understand the deep things of God to
discern his lead in our lives to detect
when providence is working in our life.
Sin is the block. That is why confession
of sin is an essential rule of Bible
study. By the way, it is for me the
first rule of health. Get sin out of
your life. To understand the word of
God, we must first come confessing sin.
Forgive me the God. Remove that which
corrupts my
thinking. When Adam and Eve sinned, they
began to think differently. Instead of
running to God, they ran from God. Now
they have a mind that takes them towards
death. Sin does that. We must confess
our sins in order that we may have the
mind of Christ. With that mind, we
slowly grow and grow in the knowledge of
Jesus Christ. The knowledge of the
father, the knowledge of the Holy
Spirit, the knowledge of salvation. The
one block to understanding is sin. You
may say laziness. Laziness is sin. You
may say whatever, whatever that
interferes with Bible study is an
outgrowth of sin. It's the only block to
our understanding God's word.
Slothfulness, sin. Putting secular
things above the word of God, sin.
Anything that interferes and gets
between us and God is sin because it's
an idol. And so the block, my dear
sister and all my friends listening, is
sin. Not the absence of an academic
degree. Sin.
Amen. Amen. It is sin that separated us
from the father in the first place.
When you're separated from the father,
you're separated from wisdom. You're
separated from intelligence. You're
separated from everything that's good.
When you're separated from the father,
that's why Christ is made unto us wisdom
and righteousness and sanctification and
redemption. 1 Corinthians 1:30. He's
made that to us because we don't have it
ourselves because sin ruined that.
Amen. Amen. The fullness of the Godhead
bodily. That's right. Colossians 2:9.
The fullness of the Godhead bodily.
Colossians
2:3 who he in him dwelleth all
indwelleth wisdom and knowledge that's
in Christ we must connect with him that
that knowledge that wisdom can flow
through us that we may glorify him by
our lives and be a blessing to someone
else yes sin is the problem.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Thank you Elder Ski
for answering those three questions and
thank you sister Wasan for being willing
although you were in transit to ask
those questions. Okay. So we have we
have two more questions for our official
uh segment of the program and we have a
couple of open form questions that have
come in. So once again keep the
questions coming on the topic. All right
question six and we alluded to this
before. In discerning truth from error
are the five senses enough? Why or why
not? No they're not enough. In John
chapter 12 you go to John chapter 12
read from verse 27. Then we go to John
20 and read from verse 24 to see if
there are enough. We already hinted
they're not. We'll make it more
explicit. John 12, read from verse 27.
Now is my soul troubled. And what shall
I say? Father, save me from this hour.
Yes. But for this cause I came unto this
hour. This is Jesus talking to the
father in the presence of a multitude.
Next verse.
Sorry, I went to John chapter 20. Let me
come back to 12. No, no, back to 12.
Yeah, back to 12. Sorry. Father, glorify
thy name. And that's what Jesus said,
Father, glorify thy name. And everyone
heard him say that. Keep reading. Then
came there a voice from heaven, saying,
I have both glorified it and will
glorify it again. Now the voice came
from heaven. Here's what the people
said. Keep reading. The people therefore
that stood by and heard it said that it
thundered. All right. Now, they were
wrong. Now, they heard the voice of God
and they said that's thunder. They used
the sense of hearing and
misidentified what the sound was. They
said it's thunder. Keep reading. Others
said an angel spake to it wasn't an
angel. It was God himself. And so, I
want you to see hearing is not always
reliable nor seeing. Now in the in in
the in the realm of law, it is known
that eyewitnesses account are
notoriously unreliable. Even though
people think they see what they see, it
is you have six people looking at the
same thing, they give you six different
results. And so the eyes can be trusted,
the ear can be trusted. Now go to John
20. Read from verse 24. The question is,
can we trust the five senses in helping
us to discern? Are they enough? John 20
reading from verse 24. Let's pray again.
Father, as we continue this program,
give us wisdom, dear God. In Jesus name
we pray. Amen. Amen.
But Thomas, one of the 12 Ditimus was
not with them when Jesus came.
The other disciples therefore said unto
him, "We have seen the Lord." That's
right. But he said unto them, "Except I
shall see in his hands the prince of the
nails and put my finger into the prince
of the nailing
and thrust my hand into his side,
I will not believe." So Thomas said, you
know, Thomas was honest, I need to see
with his eyes. I need to touch with my
hands and my fingers. In other words, I
am depending on my five sensory avenues
for gathering information, touching and
seeing. Unless my sensor is satisfied,
said Thomas, I will. Now, there are many
Christians today who are just like
Thomas. They have to see optically. They
have to feel, you know, kesthetically in
order to believe. But to come to God, we
must have faith. And that has nothing to
do with the five senses. Now, keep
reading. Verse 26, I believe it is. Yes.
And after 8 days again his disciples
were within and Thomas being with them.
Mhm. Then came Jesus, the doors being
shut and stood in the midst and said,
"Peace be unto you." Now he addresses
Thomas directly. one. Then then saith he
to Thomas, Reach hither thy finger, and
behold my hands and reach hither thy
hand, and thrust it into my side, and be
not faithless, but believing. All right,
let's pause on that. Jesus called Thomas
faithless. Why? Because he depended on
the five senses.
If that's the level of your uh the way
you acquire knowledge, Jesus said in the
context of salvation, you are
faithless. He also stop being faithless
and believing. Now he demonstrates what
believing is. Keep reading.
You know Thomas said, "My Lord and my
God." Yes. Verse 29. Now that's right.
Jesus saith unto him, Thomas, because
thou hast seen me, thou hast believed.
Mhm. Blessed are they that have not seen
seen and yet have believed. That's
right. Because why? They believe what?
They believe the word. It is the word
full of the spirit that gives us the
power of discernment. Go to Mark chapter
8. Read from verse 31. Let me show you
what Jesus was trying to tell Thomas.
Mark 8:31.
And he began to teach them that the son
of man must suffer many things and be
rejected of the elders and of the chief
priests and scribes and be killed and
after three days rise again. Go to Mark
9. Read verse 31 again. Same verse,
different chapter. Mark 9:31.
For he taught his disciples and said
unto them, "The Son of Man is delivered
into the hands of men, and they shall
kill him, and after that he is killed,
he shall rise the third day." Okay, go
to Mark 10, read verse 33.
saying, "Behold, we go up to Jerusalem,
and the Son of Man shall be delivered
unto the chief priests and unto the
scribes, and they shall condemn him to
death, and shall deliver him to the
Gentiles." Now, in other words, over and
over, those are only the places where
it's reported over and over and over,
Jesus spoke the word, I will go to
Jerusalem. I'll be abused. I'll die.
I'll rise again. over and over. Now,
Thomas should have held on to
that. When Jesus rose, he forgot what
Jesus said. He wanted to see for
himself. The disciples said, "We saw
him." Thomas should have said, "Why do
you look so surprised?" He said he'd
rise. That's what he should have said.
Why do you look so shocked? His word
said he'd come back. But no, he said,
"Unless I see with my eyes." His faith
was in his senses, not in thus, said the
Lord. Now go to Luke 24, read from verse
36 because not only Thomas had that
attitude, actually all 12 had it or only
11 I should say that Judas was
gone. Luke 24 read from verse 36. And as
they thus spake, Jesus himself stood in
the midst of them and saith unto them,
peace be unto you. Mhm. But they were
terrified and afrighted and supposed
that they had seen a spirit. Now that's
all the other 10 plus Tomas. They were
all scared to death. They thought they
were seeing the spirit even though
Christ told them over and over again, I
will rise. Keep reading.
And he said unto them, why are ye
troubled? Yes. And why do thoughts arise
in your hearts? Pause. If they had
simply believed what Jesus said, they
would not have been troubled. There
would have been no questions in their
mind. Jesus said, why are you troubled?
as if to say, "Don't you recall I told
you in Mark 8, Mark 9, Mark 10 that this
will happen? Why are you troubled?"
Why do thoughts rise in your heart? Mhm.
Yes. Behold my hands and my feet that it
is I myself.
Handle me and see for a spirit hath not
flesh and bones as ye see me have.
Observe what Jesus said. He said,
"Behold my hands and my feet." In other
words, he is honoring the fact that they
have eyes. You see, because he gave them
the senses. So, he honors the fact they
have eyes. He says, "Handle me." He
honors the fact they have the sense of
touch. Thomas wanted to depend only on
those things. God is saying that's
faithlessness. So, Jesus said, "Okay, go
ahead. Look at me. Touch me. Now, will
you finally believe what I said, but
never depend fully on your eyes and your
ears or whatever else." Now, go to uh
second Peter chapter 1.
Read verse 16. But read from verse 16.
Yes. Of second Peter chapter 1.
For we have not followed cunningly
devised fables when we made known unto
you the power and coming of our Lord
Jesus Christ. Uhhuh. But were
eyewitnesses of his majesty. Now wait a
minute. Wait a minute. Peter says we now
he actually meant Peter, James, and
John. He's referring to the mount of
transfiguration because we were I we saw
with these that's what he's saying. We
saw it. Keep reading.
For he received from God the father
honor and glory when there came such a
voice to him from the excellent glory.
This is my beloved son in whom I am well
pleased. Keep reading.
And this voice which came from heaven we
heard. Okay. Stop. Stop. He said we
heard the voice. Earlier he said we're
eyewitnesses. So here again we have the
use of the sense that we saw and we
heard. But go to verse 19.
We have also a more sure word of
prophecy. Yes. There's something shorter
than what your eyes show you and what
your mouth tells you, what your skin
tells you. There's something more. That
is the more sure word. The word of God.
The word of prophecy. that is more
reliable than what you think you see. It
is at that level that discernment
functions my lovely daughter. At that
level discernment functions above the
sense and even though they make their
contribution but truly discerning truth
is to rise above the senses and operate
at the level of faith and there's no
faith without the word of God. That's
right. We walk by faith and not by
sight. Faith cometh by hearing, hearing
by the word of God. Without faith, it's
impossible to please God. Faith
transcends the senses.
Amen. That's my lengthy response to that
question. Ah, very robust. Mhm. Amen.
Our final
question. What is the litmus test of
truth? All right. Now, we need to define
for our listeners what is a litmus test?
Now, you can do it or I can do it.
What's a litmus test?
When you want to determine the
alkalinity or acidity of a solution,
what do you do? Yes. You add some of
that uh solution, litmus solution, and
if it's if it's uh starchy, it turns
blue. Okay. And if something else, it
turns red. Okay. Now, there's a similar
test for truth. Is there a litmus test
for truth? And the answer is yes. First
of all, let's read Psalm 119 verse 142.
Psalm 119 verse 142.
That's interesting. I nearly put that as
the scripture verse for today. Okay. All
right. Okay. Yes.
Uh-huh. Psalm 119 verse 142.
Okay. Thy righteousness is an
everlasting righteousness and thy law
Yes. The law is the truth. Now we know
the law is the whole duty of man.
Ecclesiastes 12:13 is the whole duty of
man and the law is truth. Go to Malachi
chapter 2 read verse
6. The law of truth was in his mouth.
referring to the priest. The law of
truth has to be found in the mouth of
the priest because they teach. Are you
following me? Go to Romans chapter
2. Read 17 to 18.
Behold, thou art called a Jew, and rest
in the law, and maketh thy boast of God.
And knowest Go ahead. and knoweth his
will and approvest the things that are
more excellent being instructed out of
the law. So we have the law. We need to
identify that law. Keep reading. And art
confident that thou thyself art a guide
of the blind, a light of them which are
in darkness, an instructor of the
foolish, a teacher of babes. Now read
very carefully. which has the form of
knowledge and of the truth. Uhhuh. Where
in the law? Yes. Now, which law? Read
from verse 21.
Therefore, thou 21. Thou therefore,
teachest another. Uhhuh. Teachest thou
not thyself. Keep going. Thou that
preachest a man should not steal. That's
from the ten commandments. Dust thou
steal? Go on. Thou that saest a man
should not commit adultery. Mhm. Dust
thou commit adultery? That's from the
ten commandments. Go on. Thou that
uphorest idols, dust thou commit
sacrilege? That's from the 10. So Paul,
the law he's referring to is reference
to the ten commandments and they're
called the law of truth. Okay. Now, is
there a litmus test for truth? The
answer is yes. Let's look at the litmos
test of truth. And it may surprise you
what that test is. Let's go to 1 Timothy
chapter 1. We'll read from verse
8. 1 Timothy 1, reading from verse 8.
We're trying to discover, identify the
litmus test of
truth. 1 Timothy 1, reading from verse
8. But we know that the law is good if a
man use it lawfully. All right, keep
reading. Knowing this, that the law is
not made for a righteous man, but for
the lawless and disobedient,
for the ungodly and for sinners, and for
unholy and profane, for murderers of
fathers and murderers of mothers, for
mansllayers, for hormongers, for them
that defile themselves with mankind, for
men stealers, for liars, for perjured
persons. Now, let's pause right there.
Let's pause right there. We have this
terrible list of sins and it's only
partial. We know that. Now read the end
of that verse. And if there be any other
thing that is contrary to sound
doctrine. Now here's my question for you
and for the online audience. Any other
thing beside what?
Sound doctrine. Okay. Okay. Look at nine
again. Look at nine. Look at 10. We have
a list of
sins. Your answer is right. But I want
it uh broken. The law. Is that what
you're looking for? Okay. Okay. Now we
have the law is not this. Righteous man
for the lawless. We have disobedient,
ungodly, for sinners, unholy, profane,
murderers of fathers, murderers of
mothers, for man slayers, for horongers,
for them that defile themselves with
mankind, for men stealers, for liars,
for purged persons. And if any other
thing beside what? That list. Yes. You
see, anything else beside that list that
is what? Contrary to sound doctrine. In
other words, everything on that list is
contrary to sound
doctrine. I hope my not my but the
online audience is following. Everything
on that list is contrary to sound
doctrine. Paul is saying if there
anything else you can think about that
falls into that category, they are all
contrary to sound doctrine. But look at
that list in verses 9 and 10. Describe
that list with one word.
Sin.
Sin. Sin is contrary to sound doctrine.
But what is sin? The transgression. Ah.
Now, anything that goes against the law
is contrary to sound doctrine. And I
have to say that many times because the
carnal mind hates the word law, hates
obey. Anything contrary to God's law is
contrary to sound doctrine. What's the
litmos test? The law of God is a litmus
test of truth. Any teaching, any
doctrine, any theory that directly or
slightly undermines the law of God is
false. It's dangerous. Let me say it
again. Any doctrine, any theory, any
profession, any teaching that undermines
the law of God is false doctrine. Now,
let's get some light from God's servant
Ellen White. Signs of the Times, April
30, 1896, paragraph 1. I'll give that
again. Sign of the Times, April 30,
1896, paragraph 1. The standard which is
to test every doctrine, every theory,
every profession is the law of God.
No matter what you study, whether it's
the 2300 day prophecy or you study the
health message or you study whatever, if
it minimizes God's law to any degree, is
a dangerous
teaching. The law of God is the litmos.
Is this doctrine true? Let me hold it up
to the law of God. That is the litmos
test. And Jesus Christ himself is the
law. He's not only the lamb. He's not
only the bread. He's not only the water.
He's not only the the goat, the sheep.
He's not only the shepherd. He's not
only the the whatever. He is also the
law. All doctrine that's reliable should
point to Christ and enlighten our
understanding of him. Any doctrine, I
say again, that minimizes the law, that
which made Christ give his life is
false. The litmos test of truth is the
law of God. And in the time of trouble
when the Sunday law is passed, people
have to make choices. We'll understand
that more clearly. It's a choice between
the law of God, the law of man. Keep
Sunday as man tells you or keep Sabbath
as God tells you. The litmus test of
truth is the law of God. This is not
legalism. This is Bible
truth. God took the Israelites into the
wilderness and he tested whether they'd
obey him. He gave them the law of God in
the person of the Sabbath. in the
Sabbath law. If they'd obey that, they'd
obey anything. The law, I say again, at
the risk of being tedious, is the litmos
test of truth. Any doctrine that
minimizes God's law is a dangerous
doctrine. So if you tell there's freedom
in Christ, freedom to disobey,
disobedience is
bondage. You cannot disobey and be free.
Disobedience is bondage. God delivered
the Israelites from bondage. Then told
them, "Obey him." Obedience is freedom.
Let me say it again. He delivered them
from Egyptian bondage, then told them,
"You're free to obey."
All right, let me calm down. Any other
question? Ah, amen. Well, we have
concluded. Amen. We've concluded our
open excuse me, official Q&A and we have
a couple of amens. I see sister Dra
Campbell. All right. Kelly, and a couple
others, Sister Angela and saying amen.
And we have some questions. I believe
the first person who put in a question
here is brother Andy Oundu. Okay. Uh and
he's joining I believe from Nigeria.
Nigeria is a good place. God bless
Nigeria if that's where he's from. Could
be from Kenya. Either way, God bless the
country. Amen. He says if Pilate was
looking at truth
being Jesus, why and how could it be
possible for him to have missed it?
Could it be personal conviction or his
mind was blocked by sin? Mhm.
You see, without the Holy Spirit working
in you, you cannot discern even the very
obvious things. Jesus came to the Jews.
The Bible says John 1 verse 10, he came
unto his own. His own received him not.
They did not see him as the savior. He
was standing among them. He was in their
temples, in their homes. So, let's not
jump on Pilate too much. Pilot was a
non-Jew. He came to the Jews, his
people. They did not discern him as the
savior. Up to now, the Jews do not
regard Jesus as the
Messiah. So, we have a little slack for
Pilate. He was looking at the savior,
looking at truth, the embodiment of
truth, did not recognize it.
It's a common is a common tragedy that
people look at truth and do not
recognize it. Mercy. They look at error
and they embrace it.
Amen. We
Yeah, that's why we surely need the Holy
Spirit and we have to yield to him
working through the word. Working
through the word. Yes. Yes. Okay. So,
the next question came from brother
Shane Grecian and he asks, "What's the
difference between conviction and
discernment?"
Conviction is that which the Holy Ghost
brings to you and to me to tell us you
have done wrong or you need to take a
certain action. A conviction is a
powerful impression on the heart brought
by the Holy Ghost to put someone in the
direction of an action that pleases God
because someone can be convicted to do
wrong. That conviction is not from God.
It's from the dark side. So a conviction
is that deep impression that leads us to
do what is pleasing in God's sight. That
comes from the Holy Spirit. You may
convicted to confess. You'll be
convicted to give something to someone.
Convicted. Convictions are deep
impressions. But it is the word of God
that's the final judge of the source of
that conviction. You cannot be convicted
to commit adultery and it come from God.
You cannot be convicted to work on
Sabbath. It comes from God. You cannot
be convicted to lie and think it comes
from God. There are two convictions, two
sources, Satan and God. And the word of
God is a test as to which one comes from
God and which doesn't.
Amen.
Amen. Okay.
I'm let me ask uh this next question.
Sister Mary has asked,
"What do you believe are the most pre
pressing theological challenges faced by
the Adventist church now and in the
coming years? And how can truth and
discernment prepare us for them?"
What do I think are the pressing
theological issues and how can truth and
discernment prepare us to do what?
Prepare us for them. I guess the
challenges to come. Well, there no
challenges to come. They're already
here.
They're already here. They're not to
come. They're already here. And if you
can't say they're already here, well, I
won't say anything else. They're already
here. They're not to come. Let me
mention some terrible uh errors in the
church, not official positions of the
church. Let me be very clear, which is
held by church members. One, Christ is a
created being. Two, there's no Holy
Spirit. Three, uh uh the the the Bible
is not fully inspired. Some among us
believe that the events of re uh Daniel
are not Daniel, Genesis 1:11 are not
really actual. Some believe that the
story of Adam and Eve is just
allegorical, not real. You'd be
surprised the amount of uh expensive
nonsense that people believe in the
church. And so these challenges are with
us. They're not to come. Some people
believe in the Adventist church. Among
them some scholars. I would expect that
the six days of creation represent six
long periods of time. These challenges
are with us and among us are those who
believe Ellen White was a plagiarist and
a thief and a false prophet. These
things have been with us. We don't need
anymore. We have enough false teaching.
And the preparation is simply to go to
God's word with an open mind. Let the
word talk to you and be willing to obey.
Obedience is an essential component of
Bible study. And by the way, century
Adventists, we have some special
assistance. You want to call it Bible
commentary, the writers white to
straighten us out. They're not the
scriptures, but they help us to
understand. And so these challenges have
been with us, but the most serious ones
are that Christ is a created being and a
created being cannot save you. I don't
care how far back in eternity he was
created. A created being cannot save
you. Three, two, the Holy Ghost is not
divine. There's no such thing as the
Holy Ghost. If that's the case, you
cannot be saved because the Bible says,
"If any man have not the spirit of
Christ, he's none of his." Romans 8:9,
Romans 8:16, "The spirit bare witness
with our spirit that we are the children
of God." Without the spirit of God, you
cannot be identified as a child of God.
So to deny the spirit is to deny
salvation. It is a selfdestructive
belief. These challenges are with us.
They're not to come. They are with us
and our only safety is to hold on to a
plain thus sayith the lord. Another
error is the assembly adventist church
is not god's remnant church. Everyone
who love Jesus is remnant. Now that is
another error. It sounds very uh
allincclusive and welcoming but it is
erroneous. God has a special people on
the earth and he has given us the
identifying marks as verily as he had a
special people in the old
testament.
Any other questions? Uh, just I we have
a couple more. I see on YouTube, Master
Moonaka has asked since you brought it
up, what are the qualifications for one
to be among the 144,000 in chapter 14:es
1 and 2.
What are the qualifications? What are
the qualifications in verse five?
And their mouth is no guile. Of course,
verse one, his father's name in their
forehead. That's a qualification. Verse
five is the qualification. Read that
verse for us. And their mouth was found
no guile. Uhhuh. For they without fault
before the throne of God. Yes. That's
the description of Christ in 1 Peter
chapter 1, 1 Peter chapter 2. We are to
be like Christ. We cannot be absolutely
like Christ, but our desire must be to
Christlike. We must have his father's
name on our foreheads. As far as we
know, we must be without sin and without
fault. No God in our mouths. When Daniel
was in the lion's den, Darius came to
the the door of the den. He said, "Is
your God able to save you?" Daniel said,
"Before
me, I've done no wrong, nor before you,
I've done no wrong, nor before God." In
the eyes of God, I have done wrong. In
your eyes, I haven't done wrong. A
consciousness of having done right. By
the way, in
um the the healthful living page 233
paragraph 7, El White writes, "The
consciousness of right doing is the best
medicine for diseased bodies of mind.
The consciousness of right doing we must
seek to obey God by the power of the
spirit." And therein lies the
qualification by the power of the spirit
of Christ, we obey him. And Christ
himself and the father will declare us
to be right. We cannot declare
ourselves. All we can say is, "I've
given my life to Christ completely." And
so now, don't strive to be in 144,000.
Strive to please God. Strive to please
God. Because we don't have all the
information on 144,000. But we do know
that when the life pleases God, then God
takes over from there. If he decides
you'll be, he'll put you. If he decides
not, then you won't be. So strive to
please God. In your effort to try to be
among the 144,000, you may begin to look
at others and think they're not
qualified. You try to please God and
leave the rest to
God. And the only way to please God is
to obey him. Not sometimes, all the
time. Amen. Amen. Amen. Partial
obedience prepares you for help.
Amen. Amen. We have assurance when our
life is in God's hand. don't have any
need to fear.
All right. So, I'll see if we can take
two more questions. All right. Uh, we
kind of addressed this a while back.
David is asking, "Can truth be born or
brought forth according to Proverbs 8:es
22 to 24? Since Jesus is truth, can
truth be what? Since Jesus is truth, can
truth be born or brought forth?" I
believe we we we touched on this a while
back. Okay, read that verse for us.
Absolutely. Let me go there. Proverbsap
8. Lord, please continue to guide us in
Jesus's name. Amen. Proverbs chapter 8
22 to 24. Mhm. The Lord possessed me in
my excuse me. Yes. In the beginning of
his way. Let me start over. The Lord
possessed me in the beginning of his way
before his works of old. I was set up
from everlasting. From the beginning,
orever the earth was, when there were no
depths, I was brought forth. When there
was no fountain, when there were no
fountains abounding with water? Mhm. So,
he says in the book, Lift Him Up, page
16, this is David's question. Um, he
says that Jesus is personified in this
chapter. So, can truth be born or
brought forth?
Well, yes, brought forth doesn't mean
born. brought forth may mean made made
evident to those who at that point did
not know it. You understand? It does not
necessarily mean born because you say
Christ was born who was his biological
mother. The Bible is clear in all in
many other places that Christ has always
been there. You cannot uh run the risk
of regarding Christ as having been born
in his divine state having had a
beginning. You go to Psalm chapter 90.
Lord there has been our go to Psalm 90
read verse one. We read one and two. See
what that tells us about the cradle
that's been a dwelling place in all
generation. 90 verse one and two. Yes.
Verses one and two. The prayer of Moses.
Mhm. Lord. Mhm. Sorry. Let me Thou has
been Oops. Thou has been my dwelling
place in all generations. That's right.
Before the mountains were brought forth
orever thou hast formed the earth and
the world. Mhm. Even from everlasting to
everlasting, thou art God. Now look at
those verses again microscopically.
Lord, thou has been our dwelling place.
Where? Can you now?
In all generations now, but he tells us
something about all generations. Before
the mountains were brought forth, you
know, generations before them. So that
it could mean angels because they were
made. That's a generation. You see
before they were made before the
generation of the angels I was there
from everlasting to ever. Now how long
is one
everlasting then? How long is
two? Moses is trying with limited mind
to express the eternality of the creator
from
everlasting to
everlasting. Thou art God. We go to John
1:1. In the beginning was the word and
the word was with God. The word was God.
The same was in the beginning with God.
But long as there has been God, there
has been Jesus Christ. You go to uh
Hebrews chapter 1 verse 10 verse 11. And
thou Lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth and the heavens
and the work of thy hands. They shall
perish but thou remainest and they all
shall wax all his death a garment. And
as a vest shalt thou fold them up but
they and they shall be changed but thou
art the same. He contrasts the temporary
nature of creation with the permanent
nature of Christ always there. Jesus
Christ has always existed. If you say he
hasn't existed, you're calling him a
non-ivine being. A divine being cannot
have a beginning. That's one of the
things that make God God. He has no
beginning. He's omnisient, omnipresent,
omnipotent. He's always been with us.
Christ is like that because he and the
father are one. And so when you read uh
Proverbs 8, you got to read it carefully
because symbols are used, metaphors are
used, and we have to be careful how we
apply them. Yes, Christ is called
wisdom. He's made unto us wisdom and
righteousness, sanctification,
redemption. First Corinthians 1:30. He's
all these things. But the Bible is
clear, by him were all things created
that are in heaven, that are in earth.
Colossians 1:6, visible and invisible,
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers, all things
were created by him and for him. He is
before all things. Paul writes over and
over, all things, all things, all
things. In order for Christ to have made
all things, he had to have existed
before anything
else. Because if you say someone made
Christ, then he is part of the all
things. And he he he did not make that.
Christ made all
things. He had to have existed before
anything that is made was
made. And so yes, Christ could be
brought forth in the sense that he's
revealed to be this or that to beings
that don't know everything like the
angels. The angels don't necessarily
understand all the interworkings between
the father and the son. They probably
had to be reminded of the status Christ
occupied with the father because they
did not know. So the father might have
brought him forth to say look look this
is the relation between the son and me
particularly since satan started causing
trouble. But brought forth does not mean
he was born. If Christ was born it makes
him a created being. I mean born as a
divine being so-called divine being. And
we are not to worship anything that's
created. That's the highest form of
idolatry. Well, that is idolatry. We
must not worship anything created. If
you say Christ was created, he is a
created being and you worship him,
you're worshiping something that's
contrary to God's will. We must not
worship anything that's
created. That's what Paul tells us in
Romans 1:25 onward that God was upset
with the heathen because they worship
the creature more than the creator.
In Genesis 1:1, and I hate to get so
worked up, but this is so serious. In
Genesis 1:1, in the beginning was the
word. No, sorry. In the beginning, God
created the heaven and the earth. We
have two levels of existence. God and
creation. That's it. There is no other
way to exist. You either exist as God or
as a part of creation. God being father,
son, holy ghost. In the beginning, God
created. Everything we see was created.
There is no other way to exist. I say
again, you either belong to the God
family or you belong to the family of
the created beings which include the
highest angels. We are not to worship
anything that's created. And if you say
Jesus is created and you worship him,
you're practicing
idolatry. Jesus told the devil, "Thou
shalt worship the Lord thy God and him
only shalt thou serve." Only God is to
be worshiped. Only divinity is to be
worshiped. Jesus Christ had no
beginning. Always remember the Bible is
written in language that limited minds
can
grasp. But even then there are things we
must rustle wrestle rustle to
understand. You cannot get a more
dangerous doctrine than Christ had a
beginning.
Mm- Your savior is divine, has always
existed, which makes more remarkable his
uh incarnation. That this divine being
who was a spirit, however, spirits
exist, condescended to take human form
and experience what it's like to be like
living like created beings. He took the
condition of a created being which is
contrary to the state of a divine
being. If second Corinthians uh 2
Corinthians 5:21 God made him to be sin
for us. Can do you imagine the horror of
that? The thing Christ hates Colossians
uh Hebrews 1:9 God made him that he made
him the thing he hates. And Elaw White
writes in Aaris page 755 paragraph 1 for
our sake. He became sin
itself. He experienced what he
hates. He came in a form to live like a
created being. A divine
being comes to live like a created
being. Christ is divine. Always existed
and always
will. All right. I have to speak again.
So I need to reserve some strength my
lovely doctor daughter.
Yes. Yes. Yes. So thank you so much for
your time. Ah you're welcome uh for for
carving out in your schedule this hiatus
to be with us today. Thank you very
much. Thank you. Thank you. God is good.
And may the Lord give you extra energy
for this evening as you speak to God's
people in Livingston, Tennessee. And may
the Holy Spirit continue to empower you
as you use all of your being for his
glory. Yes. May God also shower sister
Ski with his abundant. Thank you for
that benevolence. Double thanks for
that. Thank you so much. Thank you.
Thank you my dear. And God bless the
audience wherever you are. Thank you for
joining in. May the Lord bless you. Put
a double blessing on your children and
save you. But God only saves those who
allow him to save them. Salvation is
forced on no one. It is a gift that has
to be accepted. Let God save you.
Please do what he says.
Amen. Getting along with God is so
simple. Do what I say. That's it. It's
not complicated, convoluted. What did I
say? You said don't eat the fruit. Don't
eat it. What did I say? Dip seven times.
Dip seven. What did I say? Keep the
seventh day. It simple. And you obey
because of who he
is. Because of who he is. So all your
obedience is attached to the fact that
you love him because of who he is. You
obey.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pav, for
your time. You're welcome, my dear. God
bless you. Up and down, in and out.
Thank you. Thank you. God bless you,
too. God bless you, too. You must tell
the audience when your graduation date
is so we can all rejoice.
Yes. Well, brothers and sisters,
graduation from medical school is May
22nd. Amen.
2025. God is good. Yes, he is. God is
good. We are proud of you for what God
has done with you. He has combined his
power with your serious effort. That's
the way he works. God bless you and to
God be the glory. Amen. Yes, Papa. To
God be the glory. I am eternally
grateful. Honestly, I thank you. You
know, you've been there throughout my
journey. You know, my mother, my
parents, you know, all of you that are
here today, but most of all, God has
been so good. Yes. Yes. You know,
someone someone also asked the question
and I said, "I have to make a video."
They said, "How do you, you know,
balance ministry with being in medical
school and so forth?" So, stay tuned
everyone. Okay? God willing, that will
come out in the future. But understand
this, we cannot live without living for
Christ.
That's the bottom line.
Yes. Okay. Yes. And I have matched
someone. Sister Veronica. Yes. I matched
to the University of Rochester, which
I'm actually in right now. So Oh,
so God be praised. God, God be praised.
Yes. Yes. Yes. All right. Yes. Well,
thank you so much, Elder Ski, once again
for your time to to our live audience.
Thank you for joining. Thank you for
your presence and your interaction this
afternoon. I'm sorry that we weren't
able to address all of your questions,
but you know, all good things do come to
an end. Yes. And our time is limited
here on this earth. But when we all get
to heaven, we will be in eternal bliss
and we'll no longer be bound to time.
And we'll be able to expound on all of
these questions that we had on this
planet. So, thank you for your presence.
Let us stay faithful. Um, and before we
close out, I'm going to invite Sister
Christian Cattle to sing a meditative
hymn uh for us. Let
me allow her to unmute. Okay, she's
already here. Hi. Sabbath, everyone.
Happy Sabbath, sister.
Right before I do a hymn, I'd like to do
a quick prayer.
Lord, standing by a purpose and heeding
your command, honor them that faithful
fuel all hails of Daniel's fires. God,
you are excellent in all of your ways.
Let this be a nourishment in Jesus name.
Precious name. Amen.
Sing them over again to me.
Wonderful words of
life. Let
me be sleep. Wonderful words of
life. Words of life and
beauty. Teach me faith and
duty. Beautiful words. Wonderful words.
Wonderful words of
life. Beautiful words. Wonderful words.
life. Sweetly echo the gospel call.
Wonderful words of
life. Offer pardon and peace to all.
love. Jesus only
savior
sanctify
forever. Beautiful words. Wonderful
words. Wonderful words of
life. Beautiful words. Wonderful words.
Wonderful words of
life. Amen.
Amen. How
beautifully rendered. Thank you so much,
Sister Christianne, for singing that
hymn. Wonderful words of life. And today
we have learned God's word is his truth.
And we are only able to discern truth
through the power of the Holy Spirit. So
may we take a hold of that opportunity
to be empowered to see things from God's
perspective. So thank you all for
joining us this afternoon. And I also
want to give a very special shout out to
Sister Faith Augustus for allowing me to
host the session into her home and for
warmly welcoming my mother and I. And I
also want to extend thanks to Pastor
Dixon, Pastor Jonathan Dixon, and his
wife, Sister Courtney Dixon, for
welcoming me into their home when I was
in Rochester um uh last year for one
whole month. So, brothers and sisters,
God is faithful. He provides and he
takes care of his own. And I'm grateful
for those that he has used in my path to
allow me to do this ministry. So, once
again, thank you all for joining. Stay
tuned uh for next month. We will have
something on the fourth Sabbath of well
one, two, three, four. Guess what? So
that fourth Sabbath of May is when you
know that's the Sabbath after I graduate
from medical school. So we'll be having
something special. So stay tuned for
that as well. Um and we will keep the
ministry going. We will keep the
ministry going. Also keep your eyes uh
out for what we'll be putting out for
medicine and ministry. Also note we have
a podcast for medicine and ministry
where we spoke about type two diabetes
and God's health plan. We know that God
has given us a health message through
the writings of Ellen G. White through
his word, you know, and we we see that
now science is catching up to what God
has inspired Sister White with centuries
before. So, as we read, we have a more
sure word of prophecy where unto we
would do well to take heed. So, thank
you for your presence again. Let's stay
faithful. Let's stay committed. and
let's do our part as well to please God
with all of our hearts. This is this
should be our prayer in the name of
Jesus Christ. So I will close out with a
word of prayer. Father, thank you for
your presence this afternoon and we do
not want to depart from your presence.
So abide with us and as we abide with
you. We are drawing nigh unto you dear
father so that you can grant us your
spirit so that we can discern truth from
error. We do not have to be deceived.
Alth although it is easy to be deceived,
we don't have to be because you have
given us your spirit. You have given us
your assurance, the assurance of your
presence, dear Lord. Because of that, we
have peace. So continue to guide us into
truth and continue to seal us, dear
Lord, in your lamb's book of life. This
is my prayer in Jesus's name.
Amen. All right, brothers and sisters.
Thank you again. I will actually unmute.
So if uh we'll unmute the Zoom. So if
anybody would like to say anything
before we cut off the stream, just a
hiby or a thank you, you may be able to
do that. So let me come here to host
tools. All right. So if you all want to
say a word, feel free to say it now.
Let's just keep it Christian and loving.
Yes. Sister Denise, I just want to
congratulate you on your graduation.
Wonderful young lady. God has blessed
you. You are an example to many of our
young people. Hope that many more will
follow in your footsteps and I ask God
blessing upon you always. God bless.
Amen. Thank you sis so much sister
Watson. God be praised. Thank you. Oh
good night brother Shane. Thank you for
joining from France. God bless.
Yes my dear sister. Happy Sabbath and I
appreciate the fact that you take your
time out to always provide us with the
Zoom link so we can have a more deeper
experience in hearing God's word
directly from Pastor Sk. So I appreciate
that. I'm waiting for the uh the update
you and you sharing how you manage uh
medicine and ministry. So you know we
could probably take some ideas from
there and put it in our lives. Thank
you. Amen. Thank you for joining,
Brother Kelly. May the Lord continue to
use you. And once again, happy belated
birthday. We are grateful for your
dedication to God's cause. Amen.
Amen. Thank you, Sister
Wasan. Sister Spencer, so great to see
you. Oh, you just muted yourself.
God bless you. Love you. I love you too,
Sister Spencer. God bless. So good to
see you. You're looking younger and
younger. Thank you. Give mama up for me.
Will do. Will do. Okay. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. And thank you, Sister Wasan.
God bless you, too.
Sabbath.
Happy Sabbath. Happy Sabbath. Oh, my mom
is joining. Look, my mom,
everyone. Oh, you Sister Spencer. Hi,
everyone. God bless you. Siobhan.
Hi, Cleo. How are you there? Ian, good.
I see you, Lana. Yes, my attorney. Thank
you for
joining. All right, everyone. Thank you
for your presence. God
bless. And until next time, let's stay
faithful.